charles va jusque vous pouvez aller pour
donner aux gens ce qu'ils veulent
refaire une interview limites
[Musique]
gérard louvin ce que vous seriez prêt à
obliger julien courbet à se dénoncer
lui-même dans une émission entière mac
os x dénonce sur les vendeurs
est ce que vous pourriez montré les deux
demoiselles de rochefort à poil dans
playboy kényanes ont ainsi eu accès toi
tout de suite hein c'est les accès via
monte et daniel gilbert joue on peut
bien montrer de gamine de 18 ans est ce
que vous pourriez monter une comédie
musicale sur jean moulin qui se
finissent bien
ouais je vois pas les chansons qu'on
pourrait faire je cherche ses chansons
est ce que vous pourriez faire des
débats politiques dans la boue en string
peut-être que ça rendrait les politiques
un peu plus humain mais ces salaires
remettrait j'allais dire le salaire mais
table sur terre est ce que vous pourriez
faire koh lanta avec dick rivers hervé
vilard stone et charden et christophe
lambert sur une île déserte résiste
répète comme ça est ce que vous pourriez
faire renaître patrick sabatier
ouais ouais ben oui oui avec un bon
concept et tous les gens de talent ils
rebondissent toujours est ce que vous
pourriez faire une émission de télé
réalité qui s'appellerait canicule story
avec des vieux qui pardonne cimetière
les uns après les autres
canon ça y est on a trouvé sa limite
j'ai trouvé la limite désirant lovers
les geôles de monde vient de ce que vous
pourriez faire sex academy
après j'aimerais bien est ce que vous
pourriez faire une émission politique
bien l'utiliser tous des pourris tous
des pourris 2,3 pas pourri comme étant
donné de rubans de salsa and then
vraiment longtemps pourquoi t'es pas une
vraie fixée je vois qu'on le donne
vraiment à n'importe qui non c'est pas
n'importe qui en sont d'accord mais
c'est jacques chirac qui la donnent en
caisse pour qui je vais la demander
jacques casewise et nouveau président
jacquot
je crois que tu ne la méritent aussi
chaque hôte je m'appelle non non non
alors
fait chier c'est qu'il est lui ne pas
l'avoir toi ce qui me choque moi là bas
je la veux pas mais s'il l'a vu ça veut
d'accord c'est ça mon truc
dakar est ce que si le public le
demander si la public le voulez vous
pourriez faire maigrir jean pierre frick
au attend ça fait vingt-cinq un régime
qui fait et alors
mais là il a maigri la mairie et un
grossit pas moi j'ai maigri j'ai grossi
est ce que vous pourriez demandé à
florent pagny de payer ses impôts
ouais mais je les ai aidés fut un temps
c'est vrai que
ça y est les a payés coquitlam et j'ai
toujours connu et des problèmes d'impôt
scène trance tout le temps ne pas les
payer
ouais je sais pas il a du mal c'est des
grosses sommes aussi un oui est ce que
vous pourriez faire jouer andré rieu
avec kool shen
ouais parce que si vous y connaissez en
vrille yeux je suis sûr qu'ils
l'aimeraient ou alors je connais pas non
non non je connais de loin de nom ouais
tu connais maintenant rien et j'ai pas
leur fourguer j'étais en général
connaissent pas non plus donc j'ai
trouvé vos limites quand même assez
canicule story ça vous le feriez
l'attend en été prochain
le ferai pas la limite aussi c'est que
ya pas de public qui regarde ça c'est la
vraie vraie limite mais du moment qu'il
publiait regard du manque un public qui
regarde penser qu'on peut tout faire
faut pas non plus aller à l'extrême
respecter le public
je veux de toujours dire quand on dit
ouais l'audimat sodimac d'audimat
audimat égale public
donc si on respecte pas l'audimat en
respectent pas publique
moi je respecte le public je fais un
travail pour le public excusez moi c'est
êtes-vous je sais pas si vous travaillez
pour que personne ne vous regarde mes
respects j'espère qu'on nous regarde
sinon l as tort si ce serait dramatique
chaud devant c'est un michel et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de la latitude
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu